Michael when we first contacted you to
do the interview for the Six stage plot
structure we thought it'd be fun for you
to break down a script applying your
structure you obliged we were very happy
to hear that you chose a few good men
from 1992 curious why you chose the
movie nothing against it but that's good
I hope you're not miserable now in the
whole discussion a number of reasons the
first and foremost is just one of my
all-time favorite movies and I don't
really enjoy discussing movies that I
don't love I don't really like using bad
examples and so on I think it's just one
of the great American screenplays and
movies certainly the best courtroom
drama since you know 12 Angry Men and
I'd have a hard time equivocating
between those two also because it was
written it's based on a play written by
Aaron Sorkin he wrote the script and
went on to become huge as a both a
screenwriter and a television writer
because this was all predated sports
night in West Wing and so on so he's now
one of the best-known screenwriters in
Hollywood so I thought that would be
interesting to look at it that way but
also the main purpose is to kind of
clarify and make simpler my particular
approach to story structure and
character arc and because this follows
that pattern or that formula or whatever
you want to call it so clearly and in
such a straightforward way I thought it
I think it's a great example because
it's very easy to see as you pick the
movie apart where all the elements that
I talked about in structure and
character are there so I just thought
this would be a good fun one to talk
about okay excellent well let's get
started
so we'll take what the set up which is
stage one we're going to Act one you
want to start sure talking about let me
let me give a little backdrop here so
for those of you who haven't seen the
other interview we did going into depth
about my approach to the 6/8 structure
in character arc I'll review some of
that so you'll be caught up and you'll
longer
what I'm talking about in my approach to
structure or plot structure
I find that successful movies are always
divided into six basic stages and those
stages are created by five key turning
points in the script or in the movie and
even more to the point or even neater
those turning points always occur and
essentially the same place in every
movie so whatever happens at the ten
percent point of Titanic is going to
happen at the ten percent point of
Zootopia and it's going to happen at the
ten percent point of a few good men so
these are things that I think it
behooves screen writers and filmmakers
to model because if this is work
consistently in so many successful
movies you probably want to replicate
this approach in your own writing and in
terms of character arc I'm gonna get
into that and explain that as we go
through and I start talking about how
these characters are revealed and how we
go deeper into the characters and what
their inner journey in their our car and
so on like that so we'll get to that
part as far as the six stages are
concerned the first stage is as you say
what I call the set up it's the first
10% of the movie or of the screenplay
and as a screenwriter or filmmaker there
are a few key things you need to do in
that stretch first thing you must do is
introduce the hero of the movie hero is
just my term for the protagonist the
main character it's the one we're
rooting for the character we empathize
with or identify with it's the character
whose desire defines the plot of the
story and whose desire drives it forward
a hero just to clarify is not someone
who is heroic unless maybe you're
talking about a superhero in a movie but
even then at the beginning not so much
probably currently what I call a hero is
more a character who has the potential
to become heroic and in the movie
especially if there's a movie with a
character arc where the hero has to find
a certain degree of emotional courage
that's part of what the story's about is
how do they find their own heroism how
do they
move into the truth of who they are so
in the setup of a few good men we begin
with something I call an outside action
opening most of the time in screenplays
the hero is the first character on the
page and when you submit your script to
be read the assumption of the reader
will usually be whoever's name appears
first that's the hero of the story but
you can oftentimes seduce they here
seduce the reader or the audience into
the story more easily if you begin with
a moment of great conflict so the movie
will begin with something that does not
involve the hero you'll see this in da
Vinci Code where it starts with a murder
there or a number of other thrillers and
so on so in a few good men it opens at
get mo Anton mo Bay bass and we see a
soldier getting we're not quite aware of
it at the time but we see his soldier
getting smothered and find out he is
dead he will die then we cut to the
another character in the movie so we're
still delaying the revelation of the
hero The effect of that while it's a
little dangerous sometimes to have the
reader keep wondering well Who am I
rooting for here it does create more and
more anticipation okay well who's going
to who's going to be leading this parade
here where is the hero
so we're introduced to Joanne Galloway
the Demi Moore character I'll talk more
about how she functions in the story
where we meet her and we find out
there's been this death the Navy wants
her as an internal affairs attorney to
look into it they wanted her sort of
supervised she hopes they'll let her be
the attorney but she's not they're going
to assign her another attorney so all of
that is set up and we're wondering well
who is going to be assigned to this and
since the audience already knows the
stars Tom Cruise they probably have
figured out it's going to be him and
then we cut to the hero notice all of
this is still in this first 10% so about
five pages or five minutes in and then
it cuts to the Tom Cruise character
Daniel
Kaffee I'm looking down at notes because
I'm not always good at remember in
character names but we meet him and what
do we meet when we first see him he's
out hitting the baseball or a softball -
one of the other you know sailors or
whatever and another attorney comes up
and he's not shown up at a meeting
Kaffee hasn't and the guy wants to
plea-bargain a deal and he wants to
demand five years in prison and so on
and we see Kathy plea bargain that down
- no jail time just a misdemeanor and so
on because he says the guy just had a
bag of oregano he didn't even know it
was he just thought it was marijuana and
so on so what does this show us and he
finally wins so it shows us a few things
first of all because we feel sort of
sorry for this guy who had the bag of
oregano we start to like Kathy
immediately because he's on the side of
this this other guy he's a likable guy
and he seems well-liked by the guy he's
playing catch with or hitting the ball
to and so on so being likable is one key
way to establish empathy with a hero and
that's one of the main things you have
to do as soon as you introduce the hero
another thing we find out he's highly
skilled so we admire the character he
may be kind of slick and quick about how
he does it but it's kind of amazing how
he's able to get what was going to be
five years in the brig
down - no jail time and a misdemeanor
and just just something on his record
that's going to be meaningless in other
words he gets the guy off so we're very
admiring of that about him and the way
he does it is very funny and were drawn
to characters who make us laugh often
times because they also have the courage
to say things we wouldn't have the
courage to say they're not real
politically correct and he's very
sarcastic and puts people down and so on
so all of this is to introduce us to
this character and create empathy with
this hero
and then we come to the ten percent
point of the movie so all of this has
brought us to the ten percent point of
the movie about ten minutes in the movie
altogether is about
two hours and 10 minutes long if you
take away the credits so it's very close
to 120 130 minutes so let's just rough
it out and say it's 120 minutes long and
we'll divide the percentages by that so
somewhere around the 10% would be around
page 12 at page 10 or or a 10 minute at
the 10-minute mark
Kaffee reap goes and is assigned this
new case he's got to defend these guys
who are accused of this crime down at
one time obey and then right at 12
minutes he goes and reports to Galloway
this is what I termed the opportunity of
the movie it is the first new thing that
has happened to the hero everything
we've seen up to this point is and must
be the everyday life the hero is living
and has been living for some time he's a
hotshot attorney he hasn't been in the
Navy very long he's very cynical he
doesn't really care he doesn't follow
the rule as much but this is who he's
been for some time but now there's this
new event and that is he's assigned this
case he moves into now stage 2 what I
call a new situation someplace the hero
has never been and during this new
situation he has to figure out ok what
is going on in this new world I've
created it's a it's a period of
questioning it's a period of figuring
out what is expected of me here what am
I gonna do what is my goal in this
situation how am I going to go about
doing that he's gonna gradually
formulate the goal that will drive
through the story and start formulating
a plan for it but all of these next
scenes are about him figuring this out
so he goes to Galloway and he gets more
information about the the Marines who've
been accused and then they have this
banter and she's very critical very
disappointed because he's yeah you know
he's never been in a courtroom she can
tell he doesn't care he's very cynical
and so on he goes into this meeting with
Weinberg who is his best friend and also
has just been assigned to this we'll
come back to the characters of Galloway
and Weinberg in just a little while
because they both are what I call
flection characters but these two stages
on this outer journey level take us up
to the one-quarter mark the end of Act
one and at the end of Act one at the
twenty five percent mark it actually
happens right at the thirty five minute
mark if you're watching the video this
they are going to leave for one time
obey so it's no longer about figuring
out what they have to do what he has to
do is he has to defend and try to get
either an acquittal or what his initial
goal is a reduced sentence for these two
guys who are accused of murder or
accused of murdering this other marine
by strangling him in his bed so that's
basically stage one and stage two as far
as the outer journey are concerned okay
um one thing I forgot to say or we
forgot to say for sort of a commercial
interruption is as I go through this if
those of you watching the video would
like a chart of my six stage structure
to follow along if you look down
underneath the video there should be a
link there that goes to some version of
my website story mastery com if you
click that it'll link through so you can
find out how we will send you a free
copy of the chart that you can download
so you can just follow along with these
six stages if you like as we go through
them so they're free of charge isn't
that cool
okay so I was leaving off at the end of
the first two stages the setup and the
new situation before we go on to the
hero's pursuit of this goal though I
want to talk a bit about the inner
journey for the character what I mean by
the inner journey is that while the
outer journey is a journey of
accomplishment it means that the plot
level of the movie at the surface level
is about a character who wants some
visible goal there's a visible finish
line that that character wants to cross
so in the case of a few good men he
wants to
get them off of this murder charge he
wants to he starts out wanting to get a
good reduced sentence and then it'll end
up wanting to get an acquittal so that's
his goal and it's going to carry us all
the way from the beginning of act 2 to
the climax but if you go deeper with the
character to what I call the inner
journey it is a journey of
transformation and now we're talking
about how the character changes through
the course of the story it's a
transformation actually from living in
fear to living courageously and so in
stage one in the setup when you first
meet the hero one of the things you want
to notice is this hero will always be
stuck in some way well we the audience
of the reader will get a sense that
there's something that the character is
just tolerating they're not really
living fully they're not real living a
fulfilled life they're not being all
they can be if you will and we can see
when we meet Caffey that he's kind of
there he's just very flippant about
things he's not committed to anything we
find out it's sort of subtly presented
at first but his father was a great
lawyer who became the Attorney General
of the United States before he passed
away
drops a little hint of something might
be going on more than just he's a
hotshot attorney but he is stuck in this
way that's going to be the first
indication of his arc his transformation
now to understand how the transformation
for a character works you need to ask
yourself a few things about the
character and the first of those is what
is the characters wound how is this
character wounded in the past a wound
could be a painful event it could be an
ongoing situation but in any case it's
something painful that the hero or the
character who is going through the arc
believes they don't say if you ask them
they say no that's in the past I'm over
that now it doesn't have any effect on
me but we can see and we
learn that it affects them greatly
because when we are wounded in real life
just as when a character is wounded or
has been wounded at the start of a movie
then that traumatic event is going to
generate a belief a belief about how the
world works a belief about how people
will behave in certain situations just
some kind of belief it's always a
limiting belief of some in some way
connected to that pain so because his
father was so successful and apparently
had a lot of expectations of him and
because he died before Cathy was too old
because he's not that old even in the
movie now that was his wounding
experience in the belief that came out
of that is the belief that he is not
good enough he can't match up with his
father with the memories father we might
not realize that watching the movie just
this far just in the first act but there
are lots of hints that are going to be
dropped as I will point out in a second
but once the character has this belief
that they ingrain subconsciously they
don't aren't aware that this wound has
anything to do with it then that belief
is going to create a fear a fear of
replicating the pain that they suffered
in the past in a way so if he believes
he's not good enough to match up with
his father then his fear is ever having
to go into a courtroom because as soon
as he actually does a trials you know
whatever however you say that as soon as
he really becomes a real lawyer and
really defend someone in a court of law
then everybody's going to see that he's
not as good as his father was and that
would be too painful for him so what a
character does to avoid this fear that
grows out of this belief but stems from
this wound in the first place is the
character will create what I call an
identity that's sort of the money idea
in all of this my identity I mean a
persona the character will create a
false self a mask that they present to
the world it's a mask that they're not
aware as a mask they think it's who
truly are but this will succeed at
protecting them from experiencing the
the pain or the fear that granted that
belief that came from the wound a long
time ago so what is caffee do he says
well if I am NOT gonna meet up with my
if not gonna match my father if it's
going to be very painful and scary for
me to go into a courtroom I won't do it
so he becomes the great plea bargain ER
and there's even a time when Weinberg
says he's considered one of our best
attorneys because he successfully
plea-bargained 42 cases in 60 days or
something like that like that's a claim
to fame which I assume it is but it
shows this guy's identity is I don't go
into a courtroom I just figure out the
best way to plea bargain and I'm very
good at it so I get the the best plea I
can for my client so that's the identity
he is fully in in stage one and in stage
two he's going to stay in that identity
but he's going to get a glimpse of what
living in what I call his essence might
be the essence being what would be left
if you stripped away this false self its
who the character has the potential to
become and what's his glimpse his
glimpses when he meets Galloway and then
he meets his defendants because Galloway
there's a line where she says be careful
when you go down to get Moe they're very
fanatic those Marines they're very
fanatic and Weinberg says about what and
she says about being Marines and then
when he meets his clients they say we
have a code in an honor and that's what
they live by and we'll come to a point
where they don't even want a plea
bargain because it would go against
their code this is him getting a glimpse
of what being true to oneself might be
he has no code he has no honor at all
he's just slick what does she call him a
you know a bargain-basement bizarre kind
of hustler as an attorney but that's all
his identity but to be in his essence
would mean he'd have to find a code he
died to find his truth he'd have to be
closer to his defendants who lived that
way and there are lots of him
about that in stage two he goes in and
he says to Galloway she says you've got
to defend them and he says from what I
understand these guys don't need a
lawyer they need a priest making one of
his flippant remarks in her response is
no they need a lawyer and that line will
be repeated many times are you going to
be a lawyer you're gonna be a lawyer
because that's her shorthand for are you
gonna do what you have the potential to
do or are you gonna just fall back on
your usual you know hotshot plea bargain
sort of basis and that brings up one
other thing about Galloway and that is
she is one of his reflection characters
that's just the jargon the term I use
for a character's aligned with the hero
remember the hero has a visible goal
that they want to achieve the reflection
is the characters gonna help that hero
achieve the goal she and Weinberg are
both reflections because they're both
there to help him get that reduced
sentence or that acquittal but on the
inner journey level it's the character
who is going to point out the inner
conflict to the hero hold the hero's
feet to the fire and every time the hero
is retreating into his safe identity is
going to say to him this isn't you in
this case it's her saying you need to be
a real lawyer and stop falling back on
your usual identity that's pretty much
for both the outer journey and inner
journey level how stage 1 and stage 2
work now we come to the second key
turning point what I call the change of
plans this is the moment when the hero
has now formulated the goal they want to
achieve in his case he's going to get
the best plea bargain he can for these
defendants and they begin pursuing it
now the point to notice if you're a
screenwriter a filmmaker or even if
you're a novelist that whatever the
outer motivation whatever this visible
goal your hero is going to pursue that
defines your movie your hero shouldn't
start actually pursuing it and taking
action to cross that finish line until
the beginning of act 2 you got to take
an entire 25% of your screenplay just to
build up to your hero taking those first
steps everything up to now has been him
gathering information to figure out what
are we gonna do it's only when he takes
that first step of going to one Tana moe
that he's now moving toward the goal and
this is stage 3 what I call progress
because his plan is okay I'm gonna get
the facts and I'm gonna juggle them
around and figure out a way that I can
get them off with the least sentence
possible and that's when he meets
another key character in the story and
that is his nemesis that's my term for
the person who is at cross-purposes with
the hero if the reflection is there to
help the hero the nemesis is the one who
wants to stop the hero from achieving
his goal he's the one in opposition he's
the villain in this case more like a
villain but he could be an opponent if
it's a sports story or it could be a
rival if it's a love story or romantic
comedy but it's somebody who goes
against the villain and when we meet
Jessup that's the Jack Nicholson
character a few things are apparent
immediately one is he is way more
powerful than Cathy is this is a must
when you're writing a screenplay or a
story of any kind you always want your
nemesis to exceed your hero in their
power and abilities and strengths and so
on it must seem like it's going to be
impossible for your hero to overcome the
nemesis so Jessup has all the power all
the rank he puts Cathy down Cathy is
like sort of meek with him and Shia and
just wants to get out of the situation
he seems almost wimpy in the face of
Nathan jessep which is exactly as it
should be because now we're involved now
we realize the conflict is big and the
bigger the conflict the more our
emotional involvement in the story so he
starts working and working and working
towards Cathy does toward figuring out
or putting together his defense for them
now on the inner journey level remember
he's got this tug of war going on
between his identity his safe persona
that keeps him stuck in a place that is
familiar in his
for its own but it is not going to lead
to any fulfillment and by the way I
don't think I mentioned this the rule is
if the hero doesn't move into his
essence if the hero is not able to shed
his identity and have the courage to
live his truth he cannot achieve the
goal
he doesn't realize that the hero at this
point in the story thinks he'll pursue
this goal so he can keep his identity in
place but it will always follow because
you as the writer gonna make it this way
that unless the hero finds the courage
to leave his identity he's not going to
get that goal so now your hero is
vacillating moving into his essence a
bit because he's got to to move closer
to the goal but that becomes very scary
because he's lost his armor his
emotional protection is gone so then
he'll retreat and go back into his
identity so you'll see when you watch
the movie or if you watch the movie
again as you watch this during this
stretch Caffey is at times gonna seem
like a really good lawyer he's gonna do
smart things he's gonna figure out
things he's gonna know how to manipulate
things not Cathy but some of the other
characters he's coming up with ideas
other times he just wants to back off
just get a plea bargain or whatever
until finally when he realizes these
defendants are not cooperating at all he
says I can't understand these guys I'm
gonna quit I'm gonna get the lawyer
replaced and he makes that threat right
before we reach the next key turning
point what I call the point of no return
the play of no return is going to be at
the exact midpoint it's the point at
which something happens that makes the
hero fully commit to the goal because in
stage three in the progress stage the
hero is still vacillating he's got one
foot in and one foot out so Cathy knows
he's supposed to do this but he always
leaves open the option of leaving of
giving over to another lawyer of not
doing anything to make waves but then
because Galloway confronts him and says
and this is where another inner conflict
moment is she's arguing with him and and
he's
says where daddy so expect where daddy's
expectations so great that you're not
willing to actually defend these guys
and he says spare me the psychobabble
and they have a big argument and then
Weinberg his other reflection his friend
says you want to use an argument that
didn't work at Nuremberg and and Kaffee
jumps in and says these guys aren't
Nazis these are too poor you know a
Marine cadet or Breen privates or
corporals who did something you know
that they were probably under orders to
do and then galloway turn statement says
be careful you're making an argument
meaning you're starting to be a lawyer
and again she's functioning as a
reflection who's saying don't back into
your identity this is your essence
follow that and so because of that the
next day when he goes in to ask for a
different attorney and he says instead
of doing that he enters a plea of not
guilty because his defendants were not
willing to take the plea he got from the
Kevin Bacon character because they said
that wouldn't be honorable so now he's
putting everything on the line because
if he pleads not guilty he doesn't think
he can win and if he tries to win by
accusing another officer of committing a
crime he could be court-martialed for
doing that so now we're moved into stage
four what I call complications in higher
stakes and this is when the outside
world starts closing in meaning this is
when new facts come to light he didn't
no means Jessup knows that he's after
him so they're gonna try and manipulate
more stuff to go against him it means
some the soldier Markinson shows up but
says I'm not willing to testify so he
comes into the picture because he's the
one who knows the truth about what
happened and the only one who might be
willing to tell them what really went on
there but he says I won't testify so
things are getting tougher and tougher
that's the complications the higher
stakes mean if Kaffee loses now he loses
everything there's more to lose by
failure and more to gain by success and
now the obstacles get bigger and bigger
and bigger in stage four the
complications in higher stakes
we see how the obstacles get bigger and
bigger and bigger they come closer and
closer together to make the to
accelerate the pace until finally what's
going to happen is the hero encounters
an obstacle that it's going to be
impossible to overcome and this is the
moment that I call the major setback
it's something again that happens to the
hero and at that moment your reader and
your audience must believe that there's
now no possibility of the hero
succeeding it seems like all is lost and
that's what the hero believes as well
and what the major setback is in this
movie is the officer who he was going to
call on the stand who is the only one
that would tell him the truth about the
Code Red being ordered by Jessup
Markinson as the character's name he
killed himself he was the night before
he was supposed to go testify he kills
himself now their only witness to what
really happened is gone and so we have
this scene right after that suicide
where he comes back and he informs
Galloway and Weinberg about what
happened he's drunk and he is just
railing about what occurred and he says
I'm giving up he yells at her and so on
what he's doing is he's reacting to the
major setback by retreating because when
your hero encounters this big obstacle
and gets thrown by it they're going to
attempt to go back to the life they were
living at the beginning he's going to go
at attempt to go back and be the in his
identity the hotshot lawyer who doesn't
care about anything he says I can't do
anything for them there's no hope I'm
gonna give up I'm no good and so on and
it seems like all this loss their
response is going to be to retreat
they're going to give up and they're
going to attempt to go back to where
they were at the beginning of the story
in the setup so he go wants to go back
he wants to give up on his clients and
say there's nothing I can do he wants to
just I he doesn't even say what he's
going to do just let him be found guilty
because he has no hope but he's also
trying to retreat into his
identity he no longer is willing to move
into that essence that he steadily been
moving into where he really is a good
lawyer where he really is risking not
being as good as his father was but he's
really willing to face that fear and be
courageous enough to overcome it but
once he encounters this and he knows
they're gonna lose because he has no
witness he wants to go back so he gets
drunk and he yells at them until insults
galloway deeply and says there's no
point in doing this and so on he's just
very mean and so Galloway leaves with
this great line I'm sorry I cost your
set of steak knives because that was a
joke he made earlier in his flippant way
so he leaves and he's sitting there with
Weinberg and then we learned more about
his father
we've already know his father was the
the Attorney General but there's a
moment when he says you know I think my
father would have been proud of me I
think he would have made him happy to
see me graduate from law school that's
all he ever says about his father but we
see that there's something he lost with
his father dying as as early as he did
before he finished law school part of it
at least was he went to law school to
make his father proud
so obviously that was something he
deeply wanted and didn't get to have
especially if he was so intimidated by
his father and his father had so many
expectations that he didn't think he was
good enough and that's what instilled
this whole identity and so Weinberg says
you know I did a paper on your father
once he was one of the greatest lawyers
ever he was one of the greatest criminal
defense lawyers ever and he says but if
I were these two guys if I were Downey
and Dawson the two Marines who've been
accused and I had a choice between being
defended by your father and being
defended by you I'd take you any day of
the week and twice on Sunday and that's
this reflection character saying I see
the truth of who you are I see your
essence you're the one who can do this
you're better than your father was you
can't let
stopyou and that's everything that that
that Galloway has been saying to him the
whole movie
you're good up there in court I can see
the effect you have you're a great
lawyer she's told him in the past so
when he hears that then he finally
realizes okay I can't give up and now he
goes he moves in to stage five which is
the final push he's going to put
everything on the line to achieve this
goal or die trying
he goes and gets galloway says I'm sorry
I said that I'm going to put jessep on
the stand because that's the most
dangerous thing he can do because if he
doesn't get Jessup to to confess then he
can be arrested in court martialed for
accusing an officer of committing a
felony
and that's what's going to bring us to
the final push and the climactic moment
in the movie okay so here is our big
moment and I have a confession to make
I have lectured about this movie before
I love the movie I've seen it just for
my own enjoyment probably as five times
and I've watched selected clips from
this movie dozens and I was going over
just to look at the turning points on
the timer clock and I came to this scene
between Tom Cruise and Jack Nicholson
between Jessup and being questioned by
by our hero and I couldn't resist I
couldn't stop watching it is so
compelling so it's just it's to me just
one of the great scenes in any scene
that could come out with a line like you
can't handle the truth that everybody in
the world now recognizes that's that's
pretty good screenwriting so anyway all
that's left in the climax is for
everything to play itself out it's for
him it's for this character who has now
found the courage to move fully into his
essence to live fully in this terrifying
but true state it's he's living his
truth that he does have the potential to
be a great lawyer and he's willing to
put everything on the line for it and
since he's found that courage the rural
storytelling rule is he must win he must
win the case so he comes up against
Jessup he plays against
own ego and his his own sort of identity
that he won't be able to leave and he
gets him to admit I ordered the core
bread and that moment when he says that
and we know the trial is essentially
over that's the climax now there is one
beat left and we have to get the verdict
that's given but it's almost like an
after effect because the main thing we
want to know is does he does he get his
clients off of the hook for murder and
and overcome the nemesis who's trying to
stop him because he's the real villain
of the piece
now when the verdict is delivered I
think for the sake of not giving it to
Rosie and everything in a neat bow
ending they they get acquitted of the
murder they still get court-martialed or
or not court-martial but whatever it is
when you're sent out of the Marine Corps
out of the service because of what they
did but then he passes on his wisdom to
them because now we've moved into the
final stage what I call the aftermath we
need to see the new life the hero is
living now that he has now that he's
made this journey now that he's found
the courage to transform now that he's
accomplished his goal and so what we see
is after they take Jessup away and the
verdict is delivered he goes to Dawson
and Downey says you don't need to wear a
uniform to have a code and to find honor
but he's also saying is you gave me that
you taught me to have a code you taught
me to be honored because his code is the
law he says at one point in the movie I
know the law and that's right before
he's going to go go fully defend them in
stage 5 so he knows the law and then
when they're getting ready to leave
Dawson says attention there's an officer
in the room and he salutes him and he
refused to salute him earlier in the
movie when he was fully in his identity
but now that he's in he's in his essence
he is recognized by this other soldier
by this more
rather as someone who has a code and is
deserving of this respect and so he gets
a salute and then they leave and then
the final thing is him same so this is
what a courtroom looks like and then he
leaves and we know he's going to go on
to have the rewards of doing this and
one of the key things also to notice
about this scene is not only are down in
Dawson helped but the law has been
served because Jessup is gone and and
there's something about everything is in
a better place than it was before and
this is one of the things that you want
to show in the aftermath that the hero's
courage not only benefits him but
benefits those around him as well and by
implication benefits the audience as
well because it is my belief that when
we empathize with the character who's
able to transform and find that kind of
courage because we are we've become that
character subconsciously it means we've
had the experience of being courageous
we've had the experience of living our
truth we've had the experience of
showing that kind of bravery and having
a little piece of that transformation
and I think that's one of the great
things we take away from great stories
is we take away an understanding and
experience of courage and we can put
that into our lives and maybe just be a
little bit more courageous in our own
lives and facing our own obstacles and
overcoming our own identities to live
our truth as well let's take the
courtroom scene in a few good men and
break it down by beats and what are some
of the parts that make it so memorable
aside from the infamous line from Jessup
sure well it depends if you're talking
about the whole courtroom the whole
trial because the trial actually begins
at the midpoint for sure and and then it
ends at the climax really and cares all
the way to the end of the movie so
through the whole trial it's been using
a number of sort of key structural
devices one is you want to you want to
move back and forth between the hero
being
in control and the opposition being in
control so you want the audience to be
kept a little bit off balance at times
we think okay now the caffee really is
winning but then then the Kevin Bacon
character I forget his name the the
prosecuting attorney he comes back oh no
now he's winning oh no now he's winning
and now he's winning so you don't want
it to just be bad bad bad bad bad and
then good good good good good it's got
to go back and forth back and forth so
there's sort of peaks and valleys to the
emotional experience of that overall
sequence the next thing you want to do
is it also combines a couple of key
structural devices one is anticipation
and one is surprise anticipation means
we're trying to figure out what's going
to happen next and you can increase that
device or you can strengthen that tool
if you use what I refer to as superior
position so let your audience know
something that some of the characters
don't know for example we know that
Cathy's gonna try and gonna call Jessup
and try and get him to admit what he did
but nobody else knows so we're
anticipating what's going to happen when
Jessup gets up there how is he going to
go about doing that so that's actually
curiosity as well as anticipation okay
we anticipate the that what's going to
happen when he calls up the Airmen that
were in the flight tower for this
non-existent flight and calls them up to
testify so we're curious about that or
we're anticipating what's that going to
be like and and we're anticipating
what's he going to do now that Murchison
or whatever his name is has committed
suicide so a lot of it is what's going
to happen now what's going to happen
next what's going to happen next but
sometimes the audience doesn't want to
try and predict what's going to happen
next they want to be totally surprised
so the surprise is one surprises when we
learn later that those two guys from the
tower didn't know anything about the
flight they were just a red herring they
were just to make make Jessup believe
that he had evidence that he didn't have
we were given that information at a time
we
in the audience so that created a twist
that created surprise so sometimes you
want to lead your audience toward
anticipating and expecting something
sometimes you want to turn the tables on
them or jump out and go boo or do
something that's completely unexpected
the next thing that makes that work is
the obstacles just like through the
movie or getting bigger and bigger so
the testimony becomes harder and harder
and harder to get to the truth and
finally comes Jessup who we know is
going to be the most difficult thing to
overcome I mean just imagine the movie
if Jessup was the first witness and then
after that we had Cuba Gooding jr.
there's one of the one of the small
parts in this movie it's ridiculous to
anticipate because instinctively we all
know you've got to let's save the
biggest and the best for last
and then even in that final
confrontation where Jessup's on the
stand it's like okay we we have some
more superior position and that is we
know that he's terrified of doing this
and then if he fails he's going to get
court-martialed
now the other characters may realize
that but they're not they don't aren't
aware of how frightened Caffey is and
they don't know what he has up his
sleeve like we in some ways do we know
he's going to use the the shirts that he
saw in his closet but we don't know how
so again it's just this this combination
of surprise anticipation curiosity
conflict peak moments small moments and
then one last thing and that is if you
just look at the arc of Jessup's
testimony you will see that it starts
out everything caffee's trying to get
him to say doesn't really get very far
yeah he's sawing him the phone logs and
I see owning me didn't pack and there
are questions but he's but Jessup is
just very confident he says is this all
you got you know footlocker's and phone
calls you know I hope you got something
more than that these people are there on
trial for their lives and he's so sure
of himself but then as soon as he asks
him why two commands why the two orders
if he was so safe because of the first
order why did he have to be sent away
from the base and then we see the turn
and now we see
that everything's going to shift and
where it seemed like Kathy was going
down and jessup was good was rising now
it shifts and now Kathy is in control
until finally Jessup sort of you know
ruins his own future by confessing that
he he and he of course did order order
the Code Red
it's just all those things in such a
wonderful combination that's really hard
to pick it apart that way because it
still takes away the magic of it because
when you see it you just get so caught
up in it